just firstly your reaction to the diana
abbott interview she says that actually
the right thing
to for kiersten to do now is to go back
to the popular policies of the 2019
manifesto what do you make of that
well look i really don't want to be
responding to diana but i want to be
responding to the country
because dan said a few things that
actually were absolutely right we need a
policy platform
that speaks to the entirety of the
country we had a very mixed set of
results
uh over the last few days we've won our
moralities back as you said in
merseyside in manchester bristol the
west of england
and also in places like cambridgeshire
and peterborough we won from the
conservatives they won a lot of seats
from the councils in what you might call
the blue wall
but we still got a problem in the red
wall and it's too soon
after the three the triple problems that
we've had of the most dreadful 2019
general election result
we've had the kobe pandemic and we've
had a post-brexit britain we've got to
respond now
to what communities are telling us and
from what i heard on the doors right
across
the country voters are willing to listen
to the labour party again but they're
just not making that step
yet to vote for us and that's why
kierstarma has to speed up the reforms
in the party
speed up the policy making process and
to be slightly fair and people have
completely missed all
of this in the last 14 months all of the
oxygen and politics in this country
has rightly been taken up by coping with
this pandemic and seeing what happens
after the pandemic
now that we're coming out of that it
gives kia a really good chance now
to supercharge what he wants to do in
terms of policy and what to do within
the with the party
and as diane says talk to everyone from
hackney to hartley poole
and all four corners of the country in
terms of what labour's
perspective is for the future
you just described what happened on
thursday as a mixed set of results
for the labour party this is an election
where you know you lost heart the pool
for the first time since that seat was
ever created you lost control of durham
council for the first time in 100 years
you were humiliated in the tease valley
mayoral contest
even in places where you hung on you
were down nine seats in sunderland down
to six seats in oldham council
i i if some people listening will be
like you don't have a grip on what's
going on here you just described it as a
mixed set of results the conservatives
have been in power for 11 years it's not
a mixed set of results for the labour
party isn't it
well sophie i did say that we've got
problems in the red wall and that
includes
durham and sunderland and hartlepool i
said that that is a real problem for us
we have
taken 30 seats in wales which is a great
result for the
labour party meals we've been in power
there for 22 years we're back on the
park in the scottish context we've
held the large moralities we did win a
few countries but yes of course it's a
disaster
in sunderland well nobody is taking away
from how bad that is in fact we should
have lost the hartlepool
uh seat back in 2019 we've got a long
way back to gold i think there's been
about a three or three and a half
percent swing
a uniform swing across the country from
the conservatives to labour so we're
making progress it's not fast enough
it's not good enough we have to
re-engage nobody's taking away
the the significance of the things that
you've just said but also we have to
talk up the things that have gone well
and we've got a lot of listening to do
we've got a lot of speeding up of those
reforms to do
we've got a lot of speeding up of the
policy process to talk to those things
that the public have been telling us
they want the labour party to talk about
jobs
our public services the future of our
economy post-brexit britain the climate
these are all big big issues we need to
start getting on
to putting forward that positive policy
platform that will speak to all four
corners
of this country nobody's doing down the
fact that we've had a disastrous
set of election results in some parts of
the country but we also have other
very good election results in other
parts of the country too which is why
it's a little bit
i'm just gonna sorry you say you've had
good election results in some parts of
the country just you know
you you're down a seat on the london
assembly in the english count in
english councils you're down at seven
uh councils in wales admittedly
you've done well that is a one place it
feels like you've done well in scotland
you're also down
at seats in the scottish parliament in
what world is this making progress
it's not making progress you're going
backwards if anything well we're not
making progress
quickly enough and that's something that
kierst armour said he's talking about
it's about making progress okay we won
the west of england we held on to we
held on to bristol we held onto
manchester united
in the one hand we're doing very badly
but not recognized for the places where
we've done
it quite well we we know this has been a
a bad and few days for the labour party
the progress that we want to make isn't
good enough
and but on the one hand you can't talk
about hartlepool without talking about
wales you can't talk about
the fact that we're doing badly in
sunderland without talking about the
fact that we've won
the west of england and we won
cambridgeshire and peterborough you
can't so it is yes of course we're
disappointed the progress isn't fast
enough and we need to reconnect and
that's what kirsten
said he's taking full responsibility and
he's going to speed up the reforms in
terms of
both the party and in terms of the
country and we look forward to seeing
what's going to happen
in the months ahead we've got a huge job
to do in terms of recovering
from this pandemic we've got back on the
park in scotland we've done we've held
30 seats in the wales which is
extraordinary
and i think incumbency in terms of this
pandemic has been helpful
in terms of the conservatives in england
the smp and scotland and the labour
party
and well so we have to recognize the
patchwork of these results without
concentrating on the downsides and the
upsides we have to look at this sensibly
analyze what's gone wrong analyze what's
gone well
and respond to that that's what any
sensible political party that wants to
be a credible account of government
should be doing today
uh you say that kirsten was taking
responsibility for the results
is sacking angela rainer taking
responsibility
well this is another example of where we
seem to be having political dialogue
from social media angelina hasn't been
sacked
as i understand it angela has been
offered a significant
promotion to take her from the back
office of the labour party running
elections to the front office where
she's talking to the country so in
actual fact angelina
as i understand it as i have been told
has not been sacked but
kier stammer has decided to do a
reshuffle of his front bench to respond
to those election results
from the back office to the front office
i'm not aware
she's a deaf leader of the party she'll
take a significant role in the cabinet
as i understand that although i don't
know the position
she's been offered a significant
promotion that means she spends more
time talking to the country
about policy using those a great way
that she communicates and using the
mandate that she's got investigative of
the party so
that's essentially what's happening
angela reina has not been sacked but
social media
has blown up over the last 12 hours to
understand and i hope that lotto will
will i hope the leader's office will
respond to that and do the reshuffle
and you'll show that this has been this
hasn't been a second but actually
a significant way of getting angela
arena from the back office to the front
office of labor following you'll forgive
me if i'm uh
skeptical um at the fact that this is
now being spun as you know a big
promotion for angela rainer
uh when um you can't even tell us what
job she's going to go to maybe that's
been scrambled
right now by the leader of the
opposition's office after seeing the
reaction um you know we were being
messaged yesterday including myself
saying that
um kyr said he was taking full
responsibility for the result of the
elections and he said we need to change
that means change how we run our
campaigns in the future this
is not social media twitter storm this
is coming from the leader of the
opposition's
office yes and leader of the opposition
hasn't just said that in messages
to you sophie in the media he said it
publicly that he was taking full
responsibility for these elections and i
think that's
the right thing to do cure now deserves
the opportunity to reshuffle his team to
reshuffle the policy to speed up the
reforms to respond to what people have
been telling us
everyone's talking about people have
been sacked that we do the labour party
if he takes responsibility for the
elections therefore takes responsibility
for reshuffling the team
takes responsibility for reforming that
takes responsibility for responding to
those election results that's what the
leader
should be doing if he wasn't responding
in that way not taking responsibility
i'd be perfectly happy to be criticizing
is the same as dan abbott has just done
and you're quite obviously
doing at the moment but he's not he's
taking responsibility he's resolving to
do something about it and that's what
this reshuffle
it will be about um i
just want to show you a poll um it's
coming up on screen now just read you
through the uh results
just about whether or not the real
problem is kir
stama this was a poll that was carried
out
just just before an onpolling day this
week asking people for the main reason
that they weren't
voting labor 14 said it was because of
stamina
leadership that's the highest percentage
of the four options they were given
is kirsten with a problem no kirsten has
the responsibility now to turn that
around
and he's only been in paris he's only
been in the leader of labour party
in that powerful position since the 4th
of april last year all we've done over
the last 14 months has been
swamped rightly so by the pandemic he
needs time to be able to develop that
policy platform
he needs time as a leader of the party
to reshuffle the pack
respond to these elections take
responsibility that's what he's
doing and hopefully because he's doing
that that 14 percent
goes down to zero and people see kyo
stamina as being an alternative
prime minister for this country the
country needs a strong opposition but it
also seems a credible
alternative government the conservatives
can't pretend that they've not been in
power for the last
11 years they can't pretend that the
issues in hartlepool that the voters
have voted against the labour party for
are the sole responsibility of the
labour party that's 11 years they've
been
in power and they've got a
responsibility as well to not break
those promises that they're making to
the electorate at the moment so we've
got to hold this government to account
we've got to show what the alternative
is we've got to have a policy
a positive policy platform and that's
what peer star was determined to do
from these set of elections so what
should
labour do now what is the vision what is
the big
policy idea well it's got to be about
what the future of the country looks
like in a post-brexit
environment we've got to make sure that
what should it be what is the vision for
that
well the vision's got to be about
people's jobs it's got to be about
people's livelihoods it's got to be
about how we fund our public services
it's got to be about giving power to
communities it's got to be about
investing
and the places that felt they've been
left behind it's got to be about
responding to what the ordinary voter
wants the other realtor wants
a safe job they want progression in the
workplace they want good pay they want
well rewarded they want fairness they
want a safety net
they want their children to do well in
school these things aren't difficult
the policy the policy platform to get us
forward in terms of those narratives
is the thing that needs to be worked on
but that's what we are determined to do
and that's what he was determined to put
together in terms of both his team
and the policy platform going forward
okay um i just want to talk to you about
scotland
as we finish um there's now a majority
in the scottish parliament
for independence if you look at the
scottish national party
and also the scottish greens so if the
scottish parliament does pass
legislation
for another independence referendum
should the uk government take it to
court or should that be respected
well let's go back to just before the
election there was also
a pro-independence majority and the
previous scottish parliament the best
and peanut bean so this isn't new
the s p talked up getting the majority
said that would be the settled will
of the scottish people and fell short
from doing that an important thing to
realize from these elections which is
the critical for all sides of this
debate
is that scotland's completely split down
the middle in terms of the constituency
vote
pro-independence parties just fell short
of 50 percent
and on the regional list vote just got
over at 50
so scotland's completely and utterly
split there in the middle the first
minister promised that this election
would be about covert recovery
and we will be holding her to that and
if she brings a bill
to parliament about a referendum which
she promised it would be about covert
recovery
we will certainly not support that i
can't talk for the prime minister the
prime minister said he would block
a second independence referendum the
conservatives campaigned on that but it
looks if they probably
will break the promise and watching
michael gove earlier he didn't seem to
want to answer the question at all about
what the
uk government would do but what we are
doing and what our msps will be doing
when they go back to parliament on
thursday
is something that's so focused on what
everyone promised at this election
which is covered recovery that's the
priorities of scott the scottish people
that's the priorities of our msps when
they go back into that chamber and it
should be the priority for everyone
and both governments the uk and the
scottish government has to work together
to make this work otherwise scotland and
the rest of the uk
will be much diminished and if i can
just reflect on what mark drakeford
the labour first minister in wales said
after the election results
uh this week he said that he was going
to go back into parliament uh
next week he was going to concentrate
fully on private recovery and show an
aspirational bright future for our
radical whales
wouldn't it be great if that's what the
first minister said as well instead of
going back into this quagmire
and this divisiveness of another second
independence referendum that quite
frankly
is not the priority of the scottish
people at the moment